in this lesson I'm going to talk to you
about an important hetero cycle in
nature this compound which is nad or nad
P we have a little R group here so if
this group is hydrogen this is nad plus
and if this group is phosphate this is
nadp+ this compound is an enzyme helper
so enzymes speed up the chemical
reactions in your cells and they can do
a little bit of chemistry on their own
because they're made up of amino acids
we have some amino acids that have
acidic and basic side chains and those
can donate and accept protons just like
acids and bases and all organic
chemistry some amino acids can actually
form a covalent bond with the molecule
that they're acting on and that molecule
that they're reacting is called a
substrate but enzymes perform some
almost magical reactions and to do those
they need helpers and these helpers are
the coenzymes and it's going to help the
enzyme perform redox chemistry so let's
just talk about the structure of nad
often you see it just as the words or as
a small abbreviation of the structure
right over here and this is the part of
the structure that's going to be really
important for the chemistry so we can
abbreviate it like this but I want you
to appreciate just how big it is and so
when this is going to actually get into
an enzyme into the active site of an
enzyme where the reactions occur to help
it it's gonna bind very specifically
there has to be a nice big pocket that
is complementary to this large molecule
the long name for nad is nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide so let me show you
that in the structure so this is the
nicotinamide portion and this has a
positive charge on it in this structure
so that's going to be really important
to the chemistry in a minute now over
here we have our adenine and this is the
same base pair that's in DNA and the
dinucleotide portion refers to the fact
that we have these ribose units
connected to these heterocycles here so
both of these rings are hetero cycles
because we have nitrogens within
now this coenzyme needs to be
synthesized or bio synthesized in our
body and this nicotinamide portion can
come from the diet and a easy way to get
it is through vitamin b3 which is also
called niacin niacin or vitamin b3 is
actually a mixture of these two
compounds one of which is the amat Maps
on very nicely here and one of which is
the carboxylic acid many foods are rich
in vitamin b3 however if we're not
getting enough from our diet we can
synthesize this from tryptophan
tryptophan is what we call an essential
amino acid and what this means is that
humans cannot make it themselves and so
if we lack tryptophan we lack vitamin b3
or niacin and this can make you really
sick a disease associated with niacin
deficiency is called pellagra and this
was first characterized in the 1700s in
Spain and became a real problem in the
early 1900's in the southern United
States it was an epidemic among poor
people in rural areas and the origin was
they were not getting enough tryptophan
in their diet but they were getting this
disease where their skin would darken
and they'd show signs of dementia and
all sorts of problems a doctor named
Joseph Goldberger hypothesized that this
was coming from a nutrient deficiency
and he was able to prove that people
were deficient in niacin by an
experiment that he did in dogs
NAD+ promotes the oxidation of an
alcohol to a carbonyl compound now if
we're thinking about organic chemistry
we're like well we might do that in the
lab with chromic acid or something like
that but that is not compatible with
life so this part of the molecule allows
this oxidation process to occur in a
biological system without harmful
reagents and things like that let's look
at how this works okay here I'm just
showing a substituted alcohol we have
our groups we're not defining
these are and we're going to have our
enzyme do some work
I said enzymes they can act as acids and
bases and they do this really well all
the time now it's going to happen with
our arrow pushing is that this base is
going to take the hydrogen off of the
somewhat acidic alcohol that we have
here so we can show our arrow taking
that hydrogen atom now something really
cool is going to happen these electrons
are going to push down we can't make
five bonds to carbon so hydrogen with
its electrons is going to leave this
molecule and the enzyme is going to put
it in close proximity to this part of
NAD+ and that will actually accept
hydrogen with two electrons so we'll
push this down to make our double bond
and this hydrogen is going to come off
with its electrons and attach right here
now how on earth can this happen and the
magic that goes on here is because of
this positively charged nitrogen this is
an electron sink and so it can do this
interesting chemistry by neutralizing
the positive charge on nitrogen this is
an aromatic compound but the positive
charge makes it a bit higher energy so
we can continue to push electrons around
the ring and give that nitrogen right
here a lone pair and this is the driving
force for this reaction let's see what
we get out of this here's what happened
to nad plus we added a hydride here so
we have a new hydrogen with its
electrons we moved this bond over here
and neutralize the charge so nitrogen
now has three bonds and is neutral this
compound is actually called NADH and
that's the abbreviation used to
represent this reduced form with the
extra hydrogen atom and will also
produce a ketone from this reaction so
each of these coenzymes with the
positive charge has a counterpart that
has a hydride attached to it now the
concentration of nad plus in the cell is
higher than the concentration of nadh
and so there's more NAD+ available
so usually nad is the coenzyme involved
in taking alcohols to carbonyl compounds
now when we want to actually deliver a
hydride often it'll be NADPH that does
that job the concentration of this
coenzyme is higher than nadp+ and so
this is available for biosynthetic
reactions that involve transfer of
hydride let's look at one in the
biochemical pathway that synthesizes
fatty acids NADPH is going to reduce an
enol here's our reduced coenzyme and
here's our in own anons can react in two
positions right here next to the
carbonyl or at the end of this
conjugated system and in this case we're
going to have it react here in a
conjugate addition reaction or a michael
reaction in this reaction nitrogen is
going to push in its lone pair remaking
in the aromatic compound and popping
this hydride off onto the end of this
system let's do the arrow pushing so
nitrogen lone pair pushes in these
electrons are going to move over and we
can't make five bonds to carbon so
hydride is going to be added here and
I'm just gonna push the electrons up
onto carbon to make an enolate but you
could also push them through the oxygen
atom it's up to you we're going to form
our oxidized coenzyme nadp+
and this enolate which has resonance
with the carbonyl here now since this is
happening inside of an enzyme we can
just show an acidic proton on the enzyme
donating a proton to get rid of this
negative charge so the enol II attacks
this hydrogen putting the electrons onto
this basic generic basic residue and
here's our final reduced Ino n-- and our
deprotonated basic residue on the enzyme
to sum up nad is an important coenzyme
derived in our body from things that we
cannot make ourselves so we have to get
some of these precursors from
our diet this is made up of heterocycles
and this positively charged nitrogen
which you'll see in a few other
coenzymes is really important because it
can act as an electron sink it's stable
enough like this because this pyridine
ring is an aromatic compound so this
charge during this pyridinium allows a
hydride to be transferred to this
molecule producing another stable
molecule that is non aromatic KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel